Primero de Mayo en Colombia día del
trabajador un día particular después de
que el presidente de colombiano Gustavo
petróleo haya convocado a partidarios Y
sindicalistas a esta Plaza de Armas que
está situada detrás de mí y donde
también está la casa de nariño su
residencia desde el balcón ha hecho una
defensa de las reformas sociales que
busca cometer la agraria de salud
pensional y laboral un giro a la
izquierda en su discurso Donde ha dicho
que para que haya libertad tiene que
haber igualdad también ha dicho que es
el presidente escogido en el estallido
social que está cumpliendo dos años y
que fueron las protestas más grandes en
Colombia en décadas Y por último también
ha dicho qué Revolución y Reforma pueden
ir de la mano este giro a la izquierda
se suma al de la pasada semana cuando
cambió a siete ministerios y rompió su
coalición con partidos de derecha como
la u y el conservador tiene por delante
ocho semanas para llevar a cabo estas
reformas antes de que se acabe la
legislatura Pero antes hoy este mismo
lunes Sale a España para reunirse con el
presidente el gobierno español Pedro
Sánchez y el rey Felipe vi